nous accueillons notre carrière du samu
lenteur ce soit ludwig brillant
brillant bonsoir paris à 20 ans vous
étiez mimi siku un indien dans la ville
si si regardez et voilà c'est lui ce
rôle culte du cinéma français à effet de
vous un enfant star mais vingt ans plus
tard vous êtes complètement sorti du
star system vous êtes greffier stagiaire
au tribunal de bobigny
[Musique]
big rich brillant rebond soir
vous êtes né le 9 mai
1981 à soisy sous montmorency dans la
halle l'oise père chauffagiste mère
puéricultrice alors quand votre tante
inscrire vos cousins dans l' agence
bout'chou votre mère vous y inscrire
aussi et dès l'âge de 9 ans vous
commencez à passez vous vos premiers
castings toutes avaient
alors premiers rôles vous lisez des
poèmes à des chiens ouais enfin moi
j'avais lu un poème c'est ma première
apparition télé c'était ça
à partir de là vous passez au mercredi
après-midi à faire des castings et votre
rêve en fait c'est de devenir batteur ou
pour vous un batteur c'est le top
d'abord parce qu'il a les cheveux longs
et ensuite parce qu'il a une batterie
mais comme vos parents n'ont pas les
moyens de vous offrir une batterie vous
contenter d'avoir les cheveux longs
ouais voilà ça et puis ma mère a aussi
sonné ce que je fais selon elle même au
premier cheval ou bien
et un jour vous êtes sur scène à mogador
pour un énième casting ans et le casting
de la dernière chance si ça marche pas
vous arrêter un vous êtes sélectionné
pour jouer gavroche dans les misérables
alors après les misérables à mogador les
castings s'enchaînent fait un clip avec
renault oui le petit voleur tout à fait
je dansais avec emmanuelle béart en fait
un clip avec eddy mitchell aussi ouais
alors quand vous êtes sélectionnés pour
le premier rôle de l'instit vous refusez
de vous couper les cheveux sur le coup
je dis oui puis après je rappelle
financera pas
bien vous en a pris parce que quelques
mois plus tard la directrice de casting
qui doit trouver le premier rôle de m
dans la vie le rôle de mimi siku se
souvient de vos cheveux longs elle vous
appelle au départ la production voulait
un guyanais ouais je fasse que m'a
raconté c'est ce qui me racontait hervé
palud le réalisateur qui à la base ils
ont fait beaucoup de recherches ouais là
bas pour pour avoir mais ils n'ont pas
trouvé voilà hervé palud a dit si c'est
pas lui je fais pas le film quand il m'a
rencontrée il a su que c'était moi et
tout de suite si c'était pas enfin qu'il
avait trouvé son amiens et que voilà si
ce n'était pas moi ça se savait être là
pendant six mois pour préparer un indien
dans la ville vous faites de la
gymnastique fait de l' escalade
vous apprenez le le tir à l'arc ouais je
faisais des séances de tir à l'arc j'ai
même j'ai passé en fait on passe un des
niveaux au tir à l'arc et ma flèche
blanche crois que ça s'appelle je les
passais mois avec un arc d'indiens pour
le coup
voilà et donc ce qu'il faut dire quand
même c'est que dans l'indien dans la
ville
ces scènes absolument vertigineuse sont
réalisés sans aucun trucage enfin rien
n'était fait en studio en tout cas on
regarde
m
alors
autre difficulté mini sécu chasse le
serpent un sarbacane les oiseaux avec un
marc et il se balade avec mighty kg
mygale apprivoiser tu as fait une
terrafugia leblanc dit exactement
regarde
[Musique]
bien gentil mais coucou ya beaucoup mes
shows doit avoir peur c'est quoi
couillet
après c'est le cauchemar ici
c'est un fils extraordinaire
les uns scène la plus dure à tourner
pour vous ça a été d'embrasser la petite
parisienne à la fin du film c'est facile
à nivelles notre vie cocaïne
en quelques semaines un indien dans la
ville avec thierry lhermitte et arielle
dombasle miu miu et patrick timsit et
vous écrase la concurrence 8 millions de
spectateurs c'est un succès énorme
succès mondial faites votre tournée et
toute l'équipe
l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie la suède
taiwan le japon vous montez les marches
au festival de cannes il vous fait nulle
part ailleurs il m'avait fait venir en
indien en pagne et j'avais fait la météo
à l'époque je n'ai eu une énorme star
tous les gosses dans la cour de récré
rejouer les scènes du film d'expression
qui évidemment ont fait le tour de
france et ouakka tp baboune
[Rires]
[Musique]
et voilà des mois que tu me babou
alors malgré le succès vous garder les
pieds sur terre vous la seule chose que
vous demandez en fait dans les hôtels
cédés table ronde ouais je pille et les
hôtels ya toujours dans le frigo 1 c'est
vrai deux ans après l'indien vous faites
deux téléfilms et après le bac vous
choisissez quand même de revenir vers le
droit ouais dont les noms des études de
droit à l'université de cergy pontoise
parallèlement fait des petits boulots
comme tout le monde vous êtes un des
inventaires vous êtes tripper en or gris
peur savoir c'est quelqu'un qui déplace
les décors sur les plateaux animateur de
centre de loisirs et père noël avantage
de père noël c'est que personne ne vous
reconnais évidemment les là bas une fête
du poker ouais sous le nom de mimi siku
95 ouais vous serez champion d'île de
france et vous participerez aux
championnats du monde à las vegas tout à
fait ouais c'est bien mais gégé et puis
pour le coup j'ai battu laurent baffie
pour le coup parce qu'il faisait partie
des people qui est invité à aussi à
participer ce type
le problème c'est que le poker ne
voudraient pas vivre non non non vous
devenez vendeurs experts en cigares
gentil boutiques duty free à roissy
ouais t'as fait tous les boulots mari
vivait mais thébaux alimentaire hausse
puisqu'on parlait de marché de noël j'ai
fait le design tout fait quoi vous
essayez d'intégrer des cours de théâtre
à l'époque mais ça se passe pas bien
vous d'essayer de revenir vers des
professions juridiques et aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes ludwig
stagiaires greffier au tribunal de
grande instance de bobigny oui en ce
moment je suis en stage à bobigny mais
sinon je suis à l'école nationale des
greffes en fête à dijon et là je vais
choisir mon poste dans mois 2 au mois de
janvier ah ouais alors que reste-t-il de
cette aventure au début vous touchiez
plus mais maintenant chaque fois que le
film passe à la télé vous toucher 50
euros et puis vous avez à chaque fois
que le film passe 100 demandes d'amis
sur facebook ouais en fait en général je
regarde pas spécialement les diffusions
mais je suis à plus ou moins informés
par rapport au nombre sur twitter
certainement des années avec vous je
sais pas mais ça déclencherait des je
comprends j'aimerais bien être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à gaza
je
ce message à tous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux